المعارك ما زالت مستعره هنا في الشرق
الاوكراني خاصه في مقاطعه التي تشهد يعني
ضراوه في تلك المعارك خاصه في محور مدينه
باخمت التي ما زال الجيش الروسي والقوات
المواليه لروسيا وقوات فاغنر عده فئات من
المقاتلين يعني يحاولون اقتحام هذه
المدينه والسيطره عليها يعني لا بد من
الحديث ان تطويق مدينه باخمد من قبل
القوات الروسيه مستمر منذ فتره زمنيه
طويله ومحاوله اكمال الطوق مستمره في
اليومين الماضيين قوات فاغنر التي تقاتل
من الجهه الشماليه سيطرت على عده بلدات
بعد ان سيطرت على بريخوفكا ومن ثم دوبنا
وايضا اريخابا وياجد
تستهدف الان مدينه مدينه بغداد مدينه
بغداد تقع في الناحيه الغربيه الشماليه
وهي اقرب الى الغرب وهذا يعني ان التطويق
يكاد يعني يكتمل يصلون الى المناطق
الغربيه اذا استطاعت القوات الروسيه طبعا
نعلم بان الناحيه الجنوبيه والشرقيه مطوقه
بالكامل لكن كانت مستعصيه نوعا ما الناحيه
الشماليه واكمل التطويق من الناحيه
الشماليه ويوسعون الطوق غربا وهذا لتضييق
يعني الطريق الذي يؤدي الى المرجعيه
الغربيه حيث المراكز العسكريه الكبرى
الاوكرانيه بالفعل تتقدم القوات الروسيه
من الناحيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه ايضا
تقاتل داخل المدينه في معارك ضاره الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا يدافع عن المدينه حتى الان
بشراسه لكن كيلومترات عديده بالامس اظهرت
فيديوهات لق
العسكريين يؤكدون ان 1700 متر فقط تفصيلهم
عن مركز مدينه باقمت الحديث عن اقل من
كيلومترين هنا لابد من الاشاره احمد الى
ان مدينه باغموت هي مدينه صغيره كان
يقطنها في السابق 70 الف نسمه والان هي
خاليه من السكان لكن الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
لهذه المدينه التي تفتح الباب امام الجيش
الروسي للدخول الى المدن الكبرى وهي
الصلافيانس كراماتورس وكذلك قسطنطين اوفكا
الحديث عن الطريق السريع الذي مازال يوصل
الامدادات العسكريه للجيش الاوكراني حتى
الان طريق ايشاسوفيا مع باخموت تقول
القياده العسكريه لقوات باغينر بان هذا
الطريق تحت قصف المدفعيه الروسيه باستمرار
ايضا هنا اشاره لابد من ان نسلط الضوء
عليها وهي ان القوات الروسيه باتت تستخدم
اسلحه متطوره
حديثه دخلت في اطار العمليات العسكريه ان
كانت المقاتله
وان كانت انواع قنابل تصل يعني يصل وزن
القنبله الى نصف طن 500 كيلو جرام يعني
تسقط من المقاتلات يعني ترميها المقاتلات
الروسيه على مواقع الجيش الاوكراني